nous nous n'avons pas à nous soucier de rien
car nous avons le feu et nous brûlons
un sacré quelque chose ils vont
poursuivre un peu d'espace je suis vraiment désolé
pour pod ce n'est rien de grave
non c'est comme là où les étoiles  êtes la
race humaine race humaine où êtes-vous
allés donner de l'amour à comment son père est mort
un chirurgien ne tue jamais un patient et un
anesthésiste en coopération mais un
chirurgien ne va jamais n'ayez pas peur maintenant
nous verrons que vous ne pourrez pas  pour déménager
soit pour s'habituer à où elle c'est quoi
le Deuter
[Musique]
je ne comprends pas pourquoi je devrais
payer le prix mes mes enfants
devraient payer le prix
c'est la seule chose à laquelle je peux penser aussi
proche de la justice donc  ils peuvent l'éteindre